sadio moral quand tu es journaliste
spécialiste de l'afrique
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france peut être un nom sur la
personnalité du premier ministre
ivoirien qui vient de mourir
tantôt brit air tantôt son charisme
voilà comment ses compatriotes le
qualifier et pendant 30 ans aux côtés de
alassane ouattara qui naturellement
après avoir hésité à se présenter
lui-même a jeté son dévolu sur gong qui
malheureusement avait des problèmes de
santé et tout le monde le savait et on
se demandait même pourquoi ce soit alors
de cette personnalité malades de coeur
malheureusement hier le le c'était la
fin pour lui alors le décès d'un
candidat en plus celui du rhdp j'imagine
que ça rabat un peu les cartes du jeu
politique d'un pays
oui tout le monde va se repositionner et
certainement surtout alassane ouattara
qui avoue de désigné comme dauphin
amadou un amadou gon coulibaly avait j
avais fait un chantage en disant que si
gbagbo et bédié se présentait ses deux
prédécesseurs se présentait lui
également se présenterait et finalement
bagouet mis hors course budget a déjà
annoncé sa candidature pour gbagbo je le
dis parce que jusqu'à présent de la cpi
ne s'est pas prononcé quant à sa liberté
sans condition donc 10 octobre ça se
jouera peut-être peut-être a pas donc et
budget qui est dans la course
maintenant est ce que alassane or à
l'envi de se présenter parce qu il faut
le dire il n'avait pas beaucoup de soin
en choisissons gonds il n'avait pas une
palette alors qu'il ya poison de jeunes
mais je pense que sa succession n'était
pas tellement bien préparé pour que au
delà de 1 go et puis c'est avoir
d'autres jeunes autour de lui qui paie
sauf à son affaire à lui alors on savait
que monsieur coulibaly et était malade
on en parlait beaucoup en côte d'ivoire
elle a quand même été transplanté du
coeur et son état de santé suscitait
beaucoup d'interrogations on a du mal à
m
gêné que le rhdp n'a pas pensé à un plan
b le plan b pour le moment politiquement
la personnalité en vue et le sulfureux
hamed bakayoko qui n'aiment pas le
premier choix de ouattara parce que
hamed bakayoko a été propulsé ministre
de l'intérieur lorsque seront manipulés
un peu trop les milices à bouaké et qui
faisait de la mutinerie ce qui a coûté
assez cher en vie et en argent à la côte
d'ivoire est donc ouattara avait mis en
avant hamed bakayoko qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent ministre de la défense mais
je ne pense pas que ouattara avait
sérieusement penser à sa succession au
point de pouvoir trouver un plan b c'est
aux autres je pense que premièrement il
se voyait lui et il l'a dit lorsqu'il
avait annoncé avant le changement de la
constitution que c'est bédié ou où
gbagbo se présente et se présenterait
également
donc je vous rappelle que ouattara est
quand même un homme de pouvoir
je pense pas qu'il a vraiment été un
homme d'état mais un homme de pouvoir
parce que je me souviens qu'en 98 ou 99
il nous avait déjà à bamako qui pourrait
pas être candidat dans son pays parce
que la constitution ne lui permettait
pas parce que à l'époque budget avait
changé la constitution en mettant est un
être ne s'être jamais prévalu d'une
autre nationalité
or what am en étant aussi burkinabè
il avait dit que la constitution de son
pays ne lui permettait pas et à la mort
de al assad de houphouët boigny
il avait aussi tenté de se présenter
alors que la constitution disait que ses
colombes budget président de l'assemblée
à l'époque qui était le successeur
voilà constitutionnel donc à plusieurs
reprises à la scène a fait des
tentations influent des tentatives
infructueuses ou encore des déclarations
qu'il a contredit après parce que on a
vu qu'il n'a plus respecter le fait
qu'il a été peut-être prévalu d'une
autre nationalité et que s est il a tout
fait pour
présenté en contre gbagbo aux élections
dernière aux élections d'avant et
maintenant ce qu'il faut souhaiter pour
la côte d'ivoire c'est que il n'a elle
ne paye pas dans une benne plus dans le
sens et se alassane ouattara aujourd'hui
on a les clés sadio mots elle compte et
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'afrique merci d'avoir
été en direct sur arte france